[Música]
martín bienvenida the xx
durante los próximos 18 minutos vamos a
explorar el maravilloso mundo de la
cocina pero desde dos perspectivas
diferentes
el impago y la sostenibilidad
un gran reto verdad
bueno muchas cabezas deben estar
haciendo esa conexión de como tu labor
se sincroniza con este tema te propongo
que empecemos a resolver este ejercicio
bueno julliard esto empezó hace más o
menos cuatro años estaba en un estado de
estancamiento y realmente depresión
a tal punto que estaba pensando en
abandonar mi carrera de pastelería y
panadero
mi mamá un día me regaló un libro muy
bonito que se llama porno que es una
técnica hawaiana de sanación y la verdad
que una frase que me sonó mucho que
decía que si lo que está haciendo en
este momento no funciona haga totalmente
lo opuesto entonces me puse a estar más
con mi familia con mis hijos a leer
mucho a estudiar a hacer ejercicio lo
que en este momento se dan cuenta que no
estoy haciendo pero realmente todo esto
empezó como hablé como un poquito de
gran jam y vida y empecé a sentirme un
poquito mejor pero sentía que había algo
que me hacía falta y no sabía qué era
como parte natural del proceso decide
investigar lo que estaba pasando en la
industria que era que lo que están
haciendo los sets más importantes del
mundo todos los temas de gastronomía y
eso me empezó abrir un poquito el
espectro empecé a ver que había gente
utilizando productos diferentes de
diferentes zonas que todo el tema de las
historias detrás de la cocina
y generaban una experiencia un poco
mayor
la comida orgánica huertas en el techo y
eso me puso a pensar mucho
pero yo sentía que todavía falta algo y
analizando el tema lo primero que pensé
fue será que hacer una vuelta en el
techo me va a ayudar a hacer cambiar el
mundo y la respuesta fue que no
por cosas de la vida me invitan a el
lanzamiento un libro de un parque
nacional que estaba civil y que te
producido por mis socios que tiene una
fundación que se llama palmarito
cuando se termina el lanzamiento el
gerente me dice marc y yo no quiero
presentar estos pelados emprendedores
del caquetá que están como productos muy
chéveres tal vez le interesa en acerque
a ellos empieza hablar con ellos me
empezaron a mostrar frutas amazónicas
dulces pero
habían unos productos lácteos quesos
mantequilla que me llamaron mucho la
atención
[Música]
en algunos de estos momentos con
nuestros pecados me llame porque no
viene nos visita y le hacemos un trocito
para que conozca lo que estamos haciendo
y me puse a pensar que yo voy a hacer
acá que está el departamento que era el
centro de las farc en ese momento
guerrilla narcotráfico violencia pero
algo entre mineros a qué aventura se
vaya se parta que está ahí pues mira qué
es lo que está pasando
y en varios de la maleta de christie cam
así fue entonces llegó yo al caquetá me
hacen tours conocí un par de fábricas me
empiezan a explicar el tema detrás de
estos quesos que hay un tema ambiental
en fin y llega un momento en que se está
terminando el tema en florencia llegamos
a la cámara de comercio hay un auditorio
que está lleno de gente inicial por
favor si dar a la tarima estaba sentado
el gobernador
julia miranda de parques nacionales
estaba sentado el director del comité
ganaderos de chaqueta que quieren
transformación candadito y yo y termine
firmando un tema que se llama el pacto
anti deforestación que ahí fue cuando
probé por primera vez lo que se llama el
poder del queso bueno yo quiero saber
cómo un chef empieza a darle solución a
una problemática ambiental cuéntanos un
poquito más bueno para mí en este caso
fue bastante natural
el tema de
cogeré un producto como un lácteo lo he
tenido toda mi vida en mi pastelería
hago todo tipo de cosas con mantequilla
quesos crema de leche
y para mí fue muy fácil hacer la
relación no compro productos de alta
calidad de artesanal los tomos mi mesa y
no quedar mejor validador que un
cocinero comiendo estos productos y
dándose los a conocer a otra persona
pero si quisiera decirte que en mi
opinión personal no tiene que haber esa
conexión de la profesión para poder
hacer la diferencia yo tengo amigos que
son comerciantes o son médicos y cada
cierto tiempo se van a una zona rural de
colombia construyen casas para gente que
no tiene los recursos y la verdad en mi
caso por ejemplo yo soy un cocinero no
tengo más del medio ambiente y yo no
considero que hacer hay que ser un genio
o ingeniero de la nasa para poder
ayudaría a aportar un granito de arena
para que haya un cambio en la sociedad o
en el medio ambiente y pues la verdad
que para mí fue muy fácil es evidente
que cualquier persona es de su expertise
puede dar grandes soluciones para la
sociedad para el mundo
yo quiero que tú nos cuentes un poquito
más de ese gran proyecto en el que tú te
marcaste para descubrir ese poder del
caso bueno como todo este tipo de
proyectos empiezan muy pequeños
esto comenzó básicamente con dos actos o
fincas ganaderas que
fueron función a dos reservas de la
sociedad civil esto qué quiere decir que
son mini parques naturales y tienen unos
beneficios tributarios para el dueño de
la tierra y también se puede explotar
todo el tema de los certificados de
el carbón o la huella de carbono que
está muy de moda
lo que se usa con este pacto anti
deforestación es que las fincas que
entren
tiene que poner un 30 por ciento de su
terreno para que se vuelva reserva de la
sociedad civil y con esto se trata de
proteger de que esté al lado los ríos
proteger los ríos que es el agua es lo
más importante que hay y aparte de eso
pues para poder mantener corredores
biológicos y que se pueda seguir
conservando la selva amazónica en este
momento ya tenemos 17 fincas afiliadas
de 2 son 1.800 hectáreas de reserva la
sociedad civil y de las 17 ya tenemos 5
mil 800 a hoy en este momento está en el
proceso de certificación y vamos a tener
a final de año 55 fincas que van a
representar 5 mil 800 hectáreas de
reserva la sociedad civil que por más de
que parezca poco es mucho y lo
interesante es usted se preguntarán por
qué los fincas tienen 1800 y porque las
otras suman tan poquito y las razones en
el caquetá no es como en otros
donde la extensión de las fincas puede
llegar a ser de 20 mil hectáreas 10.000
hectáreas 5 mil si no la mayoría suman
más o menos entre 50 o 100 hectáreas
bueno mañana
es increíble ver como hoy hablamos del
desarrollo de un programa de una región
y de toda una comunidad
qué está pasando y qué va a pasar con
todo este proyecto y con toda esta
iniciativa que en la que tú entras y
bueno lo primero que hay que tener en
cuenta lo que yo he aprendido como
empresario desde que lo que no se puede
y probar con números no sirve para nada
entonces a mí me gustaría es mostrarle
un poquito estadísticas pero antes de
eso quisiera explicar que en este
proyecto lo que se está atacando es una
de las principales razones de la
deforestación
en el amazonas el caquetá es el
departamento que más de fort está en
colombia al año y tenemos una de las
causas importantes son los ganaderos hay
otras que son como el narcotráfico y la
minería ilegal o el contrabando ilegal
de madera sí y por el otro lado tenemos
en cuenta que la industria más grande en
el caquetá
es la ganadería y esto va directamente
relacionado con los lácteos pues tenemos
acá las empresas que producen los martes
entonces empezamos con los números de
las fincas
empecemos hablando un poco de que cada
finca en este momento aparte de su
familia que es dueña de la tierra y está
produciendo la están contratando más o
menos directa o indirectamente 8
personas más lo que refleja 8 familias
por otro lado estas fincas o actos son
fincas piloto qué quiere decir esto es
de que ellas como ya conocen todo el
tema están entrenando a otras personas
que están interesadas en entrar a este
tema de convertirse de ganadería
extensiva es lo que se ha hecho por
siglos en colombia en el mundo y
volverse ganadería sostenible es lo que
tiene que pasar en el mundo para que
podamos cuidar la tierra que no toque
tumbar selva para poder tener más
cabezas de ganado entonces en este
momento se están entrenando 1500
personas que son dueñas de su finca
y
no sé si tú puedes imaginarte más o
menos estas 1500 fincas que parte del
territorio del caquetá representan el
porcentaje bueno mejor hechas acá con
todos los expertos financieros que
tenemos acá en ezeiza pero más o menos
son 78 por ciento y en el público
alguien sabe más o menos qué porcentaje
reparación del área no medien soy la
antigua me por favor buenos expertos
bueno es el 10 por ciento en este
momento pues ya que está tiene un
territorio si es más es nada tan perdida
no están perdidas son 6 millones 500 mil
hectáreas aproximadamente
si hablamos que el 30 por ciento estas
fincas tomando como hipótesis de que
todas estos 1.500 personas que se están
capacitando entraron al proyecto del
pacto anti deforestación estaríamos
hablando de más o menos unas 240 230 mil
hectáreas esto ya son grandes
dimensiones si lo miramos desde el punto
de vista de la finca
es protestaría traduciéndose más o menos
en 12.000 empleos directos e indirectos
por otro lado
el tema de las ventas ha aumentado
muchísimo ahora quiero pasarme un poco
al lado de las fábricas
en todo este proyecto hay una marca
colectiva a la cual pertenecen en este
momento ocho fábricas pequeñas y
medianas productoras de quesos y de
lácteos
y
las ventas de estas fábricas desde que
están en el pacto anti deforestación con
esta marca colectiva
han sido de más o menos el 10% de sus
ventas que son aproximadamente 800
millones de pesos y para una región como
estos es mucha plata y por otro lado la
fábrica de estas a medida que va
creciendo en ventas en este momento ya
están
contratando aproximadamente 340 personas
cada una de ellas directa o
indirectamente para tener en este
momento en la marca colectiva 16
productos la marca colectiva se encarga
básicamente de que el queso se pueda
desarrollar con buenas prácticas que
haya una estandarización de que haya una
logística yo se encargan del
entrenamiento de todas estas cosas
y por otro lado está la denominación de
origen los quesos del caquetá fueron los
primeros productos en este país que
tuvieron una denominación de origen y
este es un ente regulador que se encarga
de garantizar que cuando una persona
comprobó que a xunta que está está
recibiendo exactamente lo que se
prometió marca es increíble ver tu
pasión tu propósito y esa
responsabilidad que tienes con el
planeta pero lo que más nos encanta es
que hubieras podido encontrar tu rumbo y
que sigas cocinando porque nos encanta
yo quiero que tú nos hagas una
invitación muy especial a nosotros hoy y
que nos contagie de ese poder de riqueza
bueno antes de entrar en ese tema yo
quisiera
invitarlos a que entendamos de que no
podemos seguir tomando por sentado de
que el planeta nos va a seguir
proveyendo de todo lo que nos da porque
realmente no es infinito en los últimos
50 años el hombre destruyó el planeta
más que en el resto de la historia de la
humanidad
en este momento yo ya encontré un
propósito y el poder del queso me ha
hecho aportar un granito de arena para
hacer un cambio
en el futuro de lo que está pasando con
el planeta
y yo quisiera ver a mis hijos a mis
nietos a mis bisnietos y a las próximas
generaciones que tengan un planeta rico
con muchos recursos y la pregunta que le
hago a todos ustedes en estos momentos y
qué van a hacer ustedes al respecto
bueno mar muchísimas gracias y los
invitamos a que prueben ese poder del
queso quema de que nos viene a presentar
el día de hoy les dejamos con un vídeo
de toda esta magia
[Música]
[Aplausos]
muchísimas gracias
[Música]